aggressively  patient you know what's funny over the  years  i've done business with a lot of people  that took me seven years to do business  with  two years to do business with six months  to do business with five years 10 years  even 15 years until they eventually do  business with me and you know what  happens sometimes i look at them  sometimes and they'll say yeah i just  don't know if this is something that we  can do together  and i look at them and i'll say ah one  of two things is gonna happen what's  that  one  i'm going to find somebody  and we're gonna run with that person you  know what's the other thing i tell  myself and i tell them  maybe in the next 6 12 24 36 months from  now we're going to do business together  but maybe not right now why  because i haven't earned my street  credit yet totally get it but be patient  you'll see what happened see  that mindset comes from you having to  earn it  earn it then you call the shots not the  other way around